we've got a woman who
is the first i believe vice
president-elect in the united states so
technically she should be
the next vice president and there's no
articles talking about
this topic of her sleeping her way to
the top she
had several appointments given to her
with an older gentleman she was sleeping
with um
who was 60 at the time and she was 29.
oh man does it get any better than that
um you know four years ago was it four
or five years ago whatever it was
when trump was running for uh president
there was all kinds of stuff in the
media about
you know grab her by the p blah blah
blah it was it was all over the media
it was a guy in a locker room that
happened to get recorded
um you know was it was it a um
inappropriate comment for somebody
running for president
whatever you guys decide but at the end
of the day he was having a private
conversation
let's dive into kamala harris's private
life a little bit to see how she rose to
power and i find it curious
myself watching this unfold in
canada as to why nobody's talking about
how she slept her way to the top or
let's just soften that a little bit
let's just say she had a little bit of
help
she had a lot of help along the way you
know we can put it that way
so this is her in case you don't know
who she is and you've lived under a rock
the last few weeks
or months uh but the now again this
article is from 2019
there's nothing current in the media
right now right like if i were to
uh let's pop up here and go kamala
the first thing that comes up is a fair
paris
i'm just going to leave it blank and hit
news
and see if there's anything in the news
this week nothing about the
uh the shortcuts she took sleeping her
way to the top
um this guy willie brown what was his
name willie brown
that uh gave her several appointments
nothing
nothing it's it's completely dismissed
none of the media is talking about it
all right let's go back over here so
this is an old uh piece from 2019
and the san francisco mayor at the time
willie brown addressed his past
relationship with senator kamala harris
in a letter to
a paper san francisco chronicle
uh acknowledging giving her appointments
so this is a plural we're not talking
about an appointment we're talking about
more than one
that furthered her career yes we dated
it was more than 20 years ago ro brown
who said he had been peppered with calls
okay blah blah blah harris did not
respond at the time
brown was married at the time he and
harris dated now
he was estranged so yes he was legally
married to his wife
blanche brown but uh they had not been
together so they weren't in a uh
official you know sounds like
cohabitating type of marriage so
he was out of that probably separated
but anyway he was he was legally married
at the time
um so he says his relationship was not
kept secret a sacramento
bb reporter told people that brown had a
succession of girlfriends so this willy
brown the mayor of san francisco
and would go to a party with his wife on
one arm and his girlfriend
on another this guy's a pimp in 1994 los
angeles times report then california
assembly speaker brown's
rush to hand out patronage jobs so this
guy willie brown described harris as
brown's frequent companion so they were
definitely
banging at the time i mean it doesn't
seem like there's any denial of that
they were in a relationship according to
this
and several people refer to her as
brown's girlfriend
again she was 29 dude was 60.
now why do you think let's just let's
just grab our beards here
and pet them a little bit and think to
ourselves why do you think a 29 year old
aspiring politician slash lawyer
was interested in a 60 year old
was it because of alpha seed was it
because he was
rock hard
i don't think so i'm sure there was
something else there
let's keep going the couple split up in
1995 which flabbergasted those who found
camilla the perfect antidote to whatever
playboy tennessee still resided in the
mayor elect's jaunty persona
although brown supported harris in her
successful 2003 run for san francisco
uh corrupt allegations albatross hanging
around my neck
uh career is over how many times did he
get her a point oh
two jobs here we go among the issues
that followed harris from her time with
brown was the allegation of
cronyism and an appointment of her two
well-paying jobs yes i may have been
influenced say sorry yes i may have
influenced her career by appointing her
to state commissions when i was an
assembly speaker
from 1980 to 1995
this guy definitely had an influence on
kamala harris's ascension
to her position twice in fact
so not just once but twice brown
appointed harris the california
unemployment insurance appeals board and
then the medical assistance commission
so this check got two appointments um
from her 60 year old boyfriend
she's 30 years younger than this dude
and she's she's
she's going for it positions that paid
her more than 400 000
over five years is that four hundred
thousand dollars a year
who wrote this article you need to
clarify that or is that four hundred
thousand dollars over the five years in
total
seems like it's over the five years so
it wouldn't be a huge amount of money
brown also gave harris a bmw
well two jobs in a bmw
strong independent woman made it to the
top with the help of willie brown her
30-year senior boyfriend look at that
and i certainly helped her first race
for districts so he's admitting here
that he helped
her win races for district attorney in
san fran
i helped her career's house he's also
helped here the careers of
house speaker nancy pelosi
oh god the difference that harris is the
only two
sorry is the only one who after i helped
her sent word okay so
this is interesting here uh the
difference is that harris
is the only one who after he helped her
sent word that he would be indicted
so this is willie harris her her 30-year
senior boyfriend
if he so much as jaywalked while she was
the d.a
that's politics for you and that's it
well
i find this interesting as hell i don't
know about you guys but um
you know she she clearly had a lot of
help getting to where she got to
um i'm sure everybody that ascends to a
position of political
uh influence in their lives has some
help along the way i mean there's no
doubt about that but
you know when you're banging a guy
that's 31 years your senior
uh who's married with three kids i mean
a strange married let's just clarify
that so it's not confusing but
you know to to get these appointments
um i don't think she earned it uh on her
own or entirely on her own
if we can put it that way but um yeah
that's
that's kamala harris and
her appointments there was another
article here that i dug up
uh because there was some confusion and
and capacity speaker brown appointed her
yeah it was two political posts first of
the california unemployment insurance
appeals board then medical assistance
commission uh what was false about that
harris had been estranged from his wife
for more so harris was not
with his wife for more than a decade yet
in that prior article people were
talking about
how he would show up at parties with his
wife on one arm and his girlfriend on
the other
so i don't know you guys decide what you
think of that
um she clearly found some beta need
there that helped her along the way
he was not alpha c there's no doubt
about that there's no 60 year old man
that's
rock hard so he didn't fulfill that part
of the hypergamy equation it was all
beta need
you